this is the white-bellied sea eagle in
the South China Sea near Borneo when
Miss Eagle spreads its wings the banded
sea snake sees the movement and dives
the Eagle is a formidable predator and
now it's on the prowl
sure enough the Eagle power dives after
it the snake can only stay underwater so
long it'll have to surface for the
briefest moment to get some oxygen and
in that moment the Eagle has harvested
the sea snake to provide food for the
next generation believe it or not snake
fed baby eaglets are more likely to
survive in the wild than chicks raised
on other foods like most parents adult
Eagles will do whatever it takes to give
their kids the edge if that means
learning how to bag sea snakes tap so be
it someday maybe these chicks will do
the same for their babies let's take a
look at another capture
as this eagle soars upward with his
prize the snake makes it his business to
paralyze the Eagle with a deadly dose of
snake venom
let's slow it down
as you can see here the snake does get a
piece of the Eagles leg but doesn't
quite get the chance to inject the venom
the Eagle wins it takes a magnificent
well deserved victory lap to the cheers
of the throng
[Music]